but even the way you get to promote
yourself though when you're running for
an election especially a presidential
election there's some very specific
restrictions in Brazil that we don't
have here right so okay can you go into
that a little bit also because I think
that most people don't know that in here
you can just go raise some Capital get
some money and and you up and running
promoting yourself uh bolsonaro did not
have the ability to promote himself when
he was running for the first time
because he's got to be organized in a
very specific weight how does it work
though and what he have to do to
overcome that very specific limitation
he couldn't go through regular media he
couldn't go he didn't spend money he won
a presidential election with like four
million one million
less than one million dollars even if he
wanted
even if he wanted to by the way even if
he wanted to he couldn't because the
median there's some restrictions media
wise right you need the parties correct
you have to be organized restriction yes
correct you need the parties uh they use
public money in one party in Brazil
can't run as an independent yeah that's
the line how many how many parties are
there many one many 31 yeah okay got it
but you need a party and the party use
uh public money taxes money yeah yeah so
who's so can I go campaign and raise a
billion and a half or two billion like
Hillary Clinton Obama no you can't no
there's no more uh company uh money
anymore they they passed the law many
years ago after after car wash actually
who passed the law
the Congress okay what do you guys think
about the fact that money can't be
involved in politics well I think it's
worse to have a public money attack
taxpayers money so public money can be
private money can't yes I believe the
figure it out for four billion no no
that's [ __ ] I agree so you want to
use my money to go campaign for your
election for the guys you don't want to
vote isn't this the replacement she did
that right she used a bunch of the money
and she got caught using the money yeah
exactly I got you so okay so going back
for the question you ask because that's
very important if you can address it no
it's very important to understand what
what happened this election
okay I think you were talking about 2018
first time he was elected very correct
the first time that was the the knife
issue and and that helped him a lot but
this time the we have in Brazil uh
Electro Justice correct like it's a
branch of uh the Supreme Court uh three
justices uh from the Supreme Court uh
takes uh uh they control the the this
electoral Justice and it's very
important what he's saying that Brazil
system is very different from the US U.S
as a state election system okay in
Brazil it's so centralized yeah into a
all-powerful court yes okay this court
has all the power and and we can't get
into the details on how they even uh
became more powerful during this
election they gave themselves more
Powers which is a different subject but
the system it's first all electronic no
Paper Trails okay everything's done
through a machine uh and it's all
centralized in a superior elect natural
Court the court is composed by judges
and justices so the main guys are three
guys from the Supreme Court and then
we're gonna come to Alexander de mores
this is the most important name here
today I think so yeah so uh he was the
one him and Sergio Moore I want to know
about Sergio moros yeah but let's start
off with Alexander first no because this
guy is like seriously like he's uh where
did he go because he's a bad guy from my
question before we move on to that my
question is he absolutely couldn't
compete at the same level so where did
he go he have to go dude
that first one first one he gets elected
he doesn't have the structure he he
doesn't have the organization so he
doesn't have access to the money he goes
where social media doesn't it yeah
social media so that's another
similarity he's with Donald Trump he
actually gets elected but he doesn't
have the money he did it with a million
without a million dollars he was at his
place we're not talking he was a small
country
his place he took a microphone uh a
church cell phone turned on the camera
in a Chip's cell phone it was like uh hi
my name is bolsonaro and that's it and
like million millions of views and it
was very organic very uh natural what
happened you know he's a juggernaut on
social media he's uh I I don't I have
never seen anyone like him not even
Donald Trump it's unbelievable the the
level of Engagement that people yeah
which one does he use so he's got a
YouTube
is he is he all across like Facebook
because Trump was mainly Twitter and
Facebook no he's all across he's it he
has a weekly live on Thursdays he used
to uh have a weekly live on Thursdays
that would always get a lot of you where
is he right now home he's in Brazil
right now and his content is live
YouTube lets it play they don't take his
content no they took no they took they
took that and and his uh supporters as
well so that that was that that well
that was after 2018 yeah 2018 2018.
remember 2018 was before 2020. that's
when social media big Tech went crazy
2020. okay before that and it's a very
another similarity with the United
States after bolsonaro won doing this in
2018 with one million dollar in social
media they got together the system and
decided we cannot allow that to happen
again so we need to fight fake news and
all that and they started the censorship
that we have right now in Brazil so with
all the craziness taking place I believe
future looks bright if you believe
future looks bright get your latest
Future looks bright hat of valuetainment
it says future looks right here future
looks bright here we got them in white
we got them in Black we got them in red
are black on black sold out these are
about to sell out if you haven't ordered
one yet we had a person in Michigan but
one then he bought three then when those
three people weren't in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks spread toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]